[Musique]
bonjour jean mais si y'a merci beaucoup
d'être le jour avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france après la
manifestation de génération identitaire
ce week-end plusieurs élus du
rassemblement national ont donc vu leur
page facebook bloqué après la diffusion
de messages qui était lié à cette
manifestation
on va regarder la réaction marion
maréchal qui en a été victime ou bien de
jordan bardella regarder suite à mon
message de soutien génération
identitaire facebook a bloqué ma page je
ne peux plus publiés les gars femmes
sont dans une démarche de censure
idéologique et politique en dehors de
tout cadre judiciaire
facebook s'arrogent le droit de
supprimer mes publications défendant la
liberté d'expression et dénonçant la
dérive liberticide du gouvernement
jusqu'à la censure pure et simple de ma
page sans recours possible si on vous
supprime votre compte vous perdez tous
vos contacts c'est très pénalisant pour
nos élus c'est une modération
bolchévique au numérique de la part de
facebook gens mais s'il ya ça vous êtes
arrivé également un oui ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs plusieurs reprises facebook
uniquement parce que les autres réseaux
on va dire ils utilisent d'autres
d'autres méthodes notamment de bridage
des comptes etc
mais facebook supprime purement et
simplement j'avais déjà d'ailleurs fait
circuler une pétition c'est à la censure
de mappage il ya quelques semaines
pétition qui avait recueilli 6500
signatures et suite à laquelle facebook
effectivement m'avait autorisé à publier
de nouveau alors il faut savoir que vos
confrères je crois du huffington post
ont interrogé la direction de facebook
suite à ces censures et la direction de
facebook a fait il répond c'est
hallucinant quand elle a dit que
finalement il suspendait
systématiquement tous les comptes qui
soutenaient des organisations appelant à
la haine de personnes à raison de leur
origine de leur race de leur religion
etc
sauf que dans le cas d'espèce génération
identitaire n'a jamais été condamné pour
de tels agissements ou pour une telle
haine
donc ça veut dire que en fait facebook
après avoir essayé de créer une monnaie
crée maintenant et justice voilà donc en
fait ils se prennent pour un état dans
l'état
donc ils condamnent en fait ils
suppriment qu'ils veulent et condamnent
qu'ils veulent alors même que les
tribunaux la justice du pays et n'a
jamais condamné génération ils ont été
d'accord ce soir génération et dans des
terres jusque cette justice n'est pas la
bonne mais c'est la leur qu'ils vont
appliquer et quels recours
justement peut-il y avoir face à ces
censures finalement écouté le seul le
recours populaire si je puis dire c'est
à dire qu'il faut comme disent les
américains et mme shem c'est à dire
qu'il faut le il faut ébruiter cette
censure inadmissible sur les autres
réseaux sociaux ce qui en l'espèce a été
fait ce que j'ai fait moi même en
montant quand ça m'est arrivé est là sa
force effectivement facebook à agir mais
cela dit c'est pas parce qu'ils vont
rétablir votre page qui rétablisse les
publications incriminé donc en fait la
censure reste c'est à dire que le
sensuel leone puis c'est une censure si
vous voulez à géométrie variable puisque
ce facebook ne vois aucune espèce de
d'incitation à la haine d'organisations
comme la ligue de défense noire
africaine qui est une organisation
suprématiste noir qui vise à aa
comment dirais-je à lutter contre tout
ce qui est pas noir et donc sur les
réseaux sociaux y compris sur facebook
quand leur président va au mali et
traite nos soldats de terroristes qui
les ont des postes anti-france
antifrançais et anti blancs ça pose
aucun problème à facebook
les facebook ne considère pas que c'est
un appel à la haine de la même façon que
certains comptes qu'islamistes qui
diffusent de la propagande islamiste sur
le réseau ça ne pose aucun espèce de
problèmes y compris l'apologie du
terrorisme
par contre soutenir une organisation qui
n'a jamais été condamné par la justice
française pour quelques agissements que
ce soit là facebook par idéologie
s'arrogent le droit de suspendre et les
comptes qui publie ces puces et ses
soutiens
donc moi je trouve ça lamentable et je
pense que au lieu de faire des lois si
vous voulez à l'assemblée nationale de
censure des réseaux sociaux on ferait
mieux de faire des lois pour interdire à
facebook ce genre de comportement non
interdire d'interdire sa rappelle ce qui
s'est passé dans une mesure un peu plus
grands évidemment à donald trump
donc pour vous finalement c'est les
partis qui sont plutôt affiliés au
rassemblement national qui en font les
frais c'est évident je dire là par
exemple je vous it est un exemple que je
traite et ce matin vous avez depuis
dimanche une photo de soi disant d'un
membre de génération identitaire qui au
moment où le président génération
d'antiquaires prend la parole sur la
place denfert rochereau vous avez
quelqu'un qui fait un salut nazi
derrière lui c'était une photo qui est
un pur montage qui a été diffusé sur
tous les réseaux y compris sur facebook
en disant les fascistes fait au fond des
saluts nazis avec génération identitaire
se faisaient cette photo est fausse il
n'ya pas paradoxalement aucun facteur de
tous les journalistes professionnels de
libération du monde et c'est qu'ils
vérifient l'info qui rend triste en
masse par la france insoumise et
facebook ne censure pas alors que là on
est dans le cas d'une fait que news pure
et simple
donc il faut effectivement qu'on
interdise aux réseaux sociaux qui je le
rappelle sont devenus des moyens
d'expression politique indispensable
donc ils doivent être plurielle et bien
il faut une loi qui maintiennent et
garantissent la pluralité pour pas que
l'idéologie remplacent les tribunaux
gens mais ça on va parler de politique
de la france à présent 63 communes du
littoral des alpes-maritimes qui ont été
soumises et hier à un couvre-feu le week
end c'est ce qu'a annoncé le préfet des
mesures territorialisée c'est une
première en france et alors que la
situation elle est très critique à
dunkerque avec un taux d'incidence qui
dépasse les 900 cas le maire a demandé
un rendez vous urgent avec le premier
ministre regarde et il y a dix jours
devant l'accélération de l'épidémie
nous avions proposé à l'état une série
de mesures de prévention qui nous
paraissaient adaptée à la situation
notre appel n'a pas été entendu est-ce
qu'il a elle est ce qu'elle a raison le
maire de dunkerque selon vous est-ce que
les alpes-maritimes font figure
d'exception ben écoute et non je pense
que l'épidémie de ce proche ne se
propage pas de la même façon en fonction
des territoires mais ça je veux dire il
ya rien de nouveau sous le soleil
maintenant les mesures simulées
territorialisée sané pour lesquels parce
que le territoire national fait partie
d'une république qui est une et
indivisible dont qu'il est il n'est pas
possible
d'isoler complètement un territoire
dalloz d'ailleurs ça paraisse
apparaîtrait je dirais même
idéologiquement schizophrène de la part
de goût d'un gouvernement qui nous a
expliqué que rétablir des frontières
nationales pour isoler la france du
reste du monde au tout début de
l'épidémie était totalement infondée à
bhl que c'était un praticable pcp
comment dirais-je des de la démagogie
pure et simple
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui qu'on
isole par exemple et qu'on confie de
manière territorialisée un département
d'ailleurs ça voudrait dire quoi ça vous
donne et qu'on pourrait que les gens qui
viennent du reste de la france ne
pourrait pas aller dans ce département
mais alors il faudrait qu'ils aient des
frontières intra départementales ou
intra régional non alors après si vous
voulez effectivement des mesures un peu
plus ciblés et moins extrémiste que
celle ci comme par exemple des profs et
des parents d âge des couvre feux ar
variable en fonction des régions il n'y
a pas de problème mais vous savez le la
propagation du virus est aussi très
volatile c'est à dire que une région
peut aujourd'hui être connaître une
accalmie
et demain en raison d'un cluster d'un
foyer qui émergeraient suite à un
attroupement etc deviendrait rapidement
un foyer infectieux important de l'âge
de toute la région et du département
justement alors est ce que les mesures
territorialisée ne se justifie pas dans
ces cas là pour pouvoir agir rapidement
moi je pense que là mais les mesures
torreilles territorialisée ils sont
vraiment très souvent sans pardon
sujette à caution
encore une fois pour les jeux les uns et
ce que je viens de lire et encore une
fois il faut pas que les mesures
territorialisée masquer la stratégie du
gouvernement à sortir le plus rapidement
possible de cette épidémie on a devant
nous des exemples comme l'exemple
d'israël qui a effectivement confiné
très durement pendant trois mois mais le
confinement n'est qu'une arme
parmi les autres armes donc on peut pour
confiner par exemple n'y a pas de
problème mais déployer une stratégie
vaccinale massive de telle manière à ce
que ce confinement soit le dernier
or le problème si vous voulez c'est que
les mesures territorialisée les
confinements caractérisée ou voir le
confinement nationale ce sont des
mesures éparses dispersée qui ne font
partie d'aucune stratégie la stratégie
de sortie de crise doit prendre en
compte tous les toutes les armes de lag
elle y compris les ouvres feu les
confinements mais aussi le vaccin or en
l'absence de stratégie vaccinale parce
qu'en l'absence de doses vaccinales
je crains que toutes les mesures que
territorialisée ne soient que des
pis-aller et empêche le gouvernement
d'avoir une véritable stratégie
le pam est temps de sortir de cette
histoire dans les meilleurs délais
possibles aujourd'hui la seule chose sur
laquelle il faut insister c'est la
stratégie vaccinale
c'est elle qui nous permettra
véritablement d'en sortir un mot sur ces
repas végétarien qui ont fait polémique
qui ont été imposées dans les cantines à
lyon hier vous voyez là la colère des
agriculteurs est là la mère de paris a
étudié cette option regarder on envisage
plein de solutions à paris et ça fait
partie de ce qu'on envisage pour des
raisons pratiques
cependant ce n'est pas la mairie
centrale qui choisit mais bien chaque
arrondissement
est-ce que ça risque de faire boule de
neige selon vous j'en mets cia c'est
l'adjointe
europe ecologie les verts qui a mis
cette option est également sur la table
pour paris que pensez vous de ce choix
d'imposer des menus végétariens dans les
cantines non mais attendez c'est pas
c'est d'abord c'est pas des menus
végétariens c'est des menus idéologie
parce que le le maire de lyon en
l'occurrence et explique que c'est pour
un port pour que ce soit plus rapide on
va faire un seul menu et notamment un
menu sans viande qui nous expliquent
comme pourquoi cuir un poisson au cuire
des oeufs
c'est moins rapide ou plus rapide que
pure de la viande sans franchement là la
raison avancée est totalement grotesque
en revanche se sont démenés repas
idéologique en tout cas pour le cas de
lyon et et des repas islamo-gauchiste
puisqu'on réalité qui qui ça pose
problème la viande
si ce n'est à une certaine partie de la
communauté musulmane
j'en ai six à ces faux la viande ne pose
pas problème certaines yongzhou l'accord
n'est pas tout
écoutez en tout cas la viola ainsi parce
que l'abs on doit analyser vous voulez
donc tout l'avion certains musulmans
refusent de la manger
donc effectivement quand vous supprimez
l'avion vous supprimez le problème au
lieu de parler de repas de substitution
on va parler d'un repas unique pour une
coupe pour une partie d'une partie de la
cagnotte de la communauté musulmane
donc en réalité c'est un repas
idéologique et
les maires écolo se servent en fait de
cette crise pour voix pour comme un
espèce de cheval de troie pour faire
passer leurs options idéologiques et
leurs options islamo-gauchiste donc
comme quoi l'islam aux gauchistes c'est
packard et diversité c'est aussi et
surtout en politique
merci beaucoup je m'essayais d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rtl france